et on commence donc cette deuxième
partie de la matinale avec les suites du
retrait désastreux américains
d'afghanistan puisque l'émissaire
américain pour l'afghanistan jette
l'épongé l'annoncé a été faite hier par
le secrétaire d'état américain alors que
des discussions sur l'afghanistan
s'ouvre aujourd'hui en russie et les
etats unis justement tirs ont annoncé
finalement ne pas participer à ces
pourparlers invoquant des raisons
logistiques à des réunions diplomatiques
sont prévus dans la journée entre les
représentants de la russie de la chine
et du pakistan
demain une délégation de talibans et
notre tombe gul et pour plus de
précision on va retrouver tout de suite
antoine claireaux en direct de moscou
[Musique]
antoine claireaux bonjour alors
qu'attendre de de cette réunion
diplomatique aujourd'hui à moscou
olivier vous venez de l'évoquer une
importante délégation des talibans est
attendu à moscou ce mercredi 1 20
octobre mais dès ce mardi des
représentants de russie de chine et du
pakistan vont commencer à aborder
l'épineuse question de l'afghanistan les
états unis étaient également conviés
dans le cadre de la troïka élargie mais
ils ont finalement choisi de ne pas être
représenté à cette réunion l'objectif de
ceux de cette première réunion justement
est d'aboutir à une position commune sur
l'afghanistan et surtout sur l'attitude
à adopter face au nouveau pouvoir en
place à kaboul avant de négocier donc
directement avec les talibans ce
mercredi manière poutine ne va pas
participer aux échanges mais il en a
évoqué les enjeux il ya tout juste
quelques jours écoutez
je ne peux ni mais
il faut néanmoins soutenir la
réconciliation interarabe gagnent ils
visaient la normalisation de la
situation dans le pays nous pouvons tous
favoriser la relance de la troïka élargi
je vous prierais de soutenir ceux ci je
veux parler de la russie des etats-unis
et de la chine avec la participation du
pakistan également le format de moscou
qui réunit les pays clés de la région
notamment ceux d'asie centrale
nous préparons avoir des réunions dans
le cadre de ce mécanisme la très
prochainement les octobre
lors de ces pourparlers il sera par
exemple question des conditions de la
reconnaissance du nouveau pouvoir en
place à kaboul les différents pays
participants à cette réunion s'inquiète
également des ambitions du groupe etat
islamique en afghanistan et des risques
de contagion aux pays voisins
antoine merci antoine pour toutes ces
précisions suivra évidemment cette
réunion à moscou aujourd'hui sur notre
antenne